I get to eating this is dark signs give
me the goods you probably need that ass
whooped free the [__] nipple hey
what's up y'all it's me Janelle Monae
and I am going to be reading I'm so
excited about this I'm nervous all the
above I'm gonna be reading your thirst
tweets so let's get into how parched you
really are
thank you
just better be good too don't waste my
time because I've watched this and I
have been floored so if you're not
thirsty over me I'm gonna throw this
phone down
but I bet you might like that I'm gonna
throw this phone over your face
seductively okay so first one why is
Janelle Monae's face so Flawless too I
just want to lick mashed potatoes off of
it
crying emoji oh how cute thank you
Janelle Monae's cheekbones are a gift
from above
so cute thank you 100 confirmed Signed
Sealed Delivered Janelle Monae is a
certified daddy
Signed Sealed Delivered I'm Yours us
cute I want to caress Janelle Monae's
face and help her smooth her edges down
oh I just did my edges too I'd let
Janelle Monae walk me like a
okay all right we're getting a little
spicy all right great danes are my
favorite so if you just said great dane
then I really would have been turned on
I'm actually not kidding I would drink
Janelle Monae's bath water okay guys
listen we've heard that so many times I
drink your bath water give me the goods
thank you though thank you Janelle Monae
please eat my whole entire head I am not
worthy now this
hmm
this is dark because if I eat your whole
head
then how are you tonight you don't exist
anymore Janelle Monae is so fine all she
got to do is look at me and I'll bust
thank you
I'll let Janelle Monae talk me all right
cute I want Janelle Monae to kiss me and
stare into my eyes do I look like I want
to kiss and stare into people's eyes I
do that's so sweet so intimate oh look I
know it's been said by me probably but
holy the lazy mommy Dom energy and
Janelle Monae's record is crazy the age
of pleasure baby I agree I agree where
y'all at
bro I'll let you know Monet spank me for
hours okay you probably need that ass
whooped yeah I'll do it Janelle Monae is
a whole ass dream come true God bless
whoever gets to rub her booty at night
oh I do love my booty rubbed I do and I
like rubbing booties too I pray every
single day that Janelle Monae is having
exceptional spectacular orgasms I love
you that's so sweet so kind of you thank
you I let Janelle Monae paralyze me
stuff me in a bear suit and light me on
fire
I'd let you know Monet paralyze me stuff
me in a bear suit and light me on fire
who are you oh my God who are you
hmm don't let my skin get as smooth and
buttery as Janelle Monae's I don't think
I'd be able to handle such power I guess
I am kind of powerful so sweet thank you
for noticing
Janelle Monae is the kind of beautiful
that I can't even lust over like I want
to masturbate to her videos but I end up
writing her a poem I don't know what I'm
supposed to say am I like I don't give
you
I have so many questions there so many
questions
Janelle Monae could be an alien which
you might be on to something who wants
to lay her brewed eggs in me so they can
eat me when they hatch and I'd let her
I love it I mean I did tell you in my
song Violet starts Happy Hunting I I I I
I'm an alien from outer space outer
space
kinky love it if Janelle Monae's make me
feel isn't the most two song in 2018
I'll eat all my butt plugs get to eating
Chanel Monet's album should 100 make you
nut agreed agreed good morning Janelle
Monae please Peg Me
you just woke up
and that's what you wanted
love it I want to be Janelle Monae's
vibrator oh
that's sweet that's cute my vibrator is
well taken care of so I understand it
that video of Janelle Monae dancing in a
bikini had me throwing dollars at my
phone screen oh
okay thank you that's a really high
compliment I want to lick Janelle
Monae's armpits ah who are you where are
you come and get them oh I love it I
love it I love it shout out to all of
the hairy pits to the envy
Harry pit Community whoever had the idea
to put Janelle Monae in a wet t-shirt
deserves a Nobel Prize I accept on my
behalf
Janelle Monae putting out the seductive
ass Black queer-centered Album during
pride month like I want to have my
titties out too actually yes
free the [__] nipple titties out
let's do it let's do it and make sure
you're in a safe environment
and all those things okay I think that
was it okay all right well this was cute
some really really cute ones in there I
feel so honored and so flattered that
you guys would even go this hard you
know online keep up the great work you
know we're in the age of pleasure we
hope I hope that you guys are finding
time for yourselves you're vibrating
your own selves you're taking pleasure
into your own hands with consent with
love self-love all of those things
stream the age of pleasure and like they
said as soon as you listen to it you
know you too could bust a good one and
come and see us come and see me on tour
the age of pleasure tour we're starting
the end of August through October go to
jaymonee.com don't let it sell out
before you get your tickets to the age
of pleasure tour I love you guys so much
thank you for all your continued love
and support and to my fam you free ass
[__] I love
I love you
[Music]